last year in june apple showed off their
brand new groundbreaking universal
control feature which absolutely blew
the minds of everyone watching the
keynote and in this video i'm gonna
teach you everything you need to know to
get it set up and use it make sure
you've updated the software on both your
mac and your ipad make sure you're
signed into the same icloud account on
both devices it should work by itself
automatically but if it doesn't you can
go over on your mac and go into the
system preferences go down to the
display options click on advanced and
here you should see all of the new
options and now moving over to the ipad
side go into the system preferences go
down to general go to airplay and hand
off make sure that is on if you've gone
through this step and you're having some
issues and it's not automatically
working go down into the display
settings on the mac click add display
and you should see your ipad under the
section that says link keyboard and
mouse so if you see it just go ahead and
click it and there you go